you
that's Coulson CEO of stripe founder
co-founder of stripe welcome to the
class yes okay so we will get into that
let's have a I will have a way of
bringing that up at the end so just to
set context we just obviously went over
some some of the business and obviously
the forces at play why don't you level
set the conversation of what is stripe
why did you start the company and like
what is what was like the underlying
theory and idea behind it okay so stripe
builds api's that make it easy to go and
build an internet business and so
importantly we are for businesses where
your customer is not there in person
there in some way making a purchase for
it kind of mediated through the internet
and so kind of our customers are the
businesses the technology companies who
are integrating those api's and building
some software enabled service the the
reason we can start working on it
initially was because we ourselves were
developers and we were sort of
astonished by sort of the non-existence
of something like stripe I remember sort
of forlornly googling looking for the
kind of easy to setup thing they were
just enable you to charge a credit card
I mean we're not talking about building
a self driving car here I've got
charging a credit card and so it seems
so implausible it something like stripe
sort of would not exist right I mean I'm
trying to give somebody money I mean
like to collect money into someone else
right so the economic incentive
structure would seem very conducive to
it and but sort of surprisingly nothing
like it existed now obviously they were
online transactions before stripe but
what happened was they were enabled by
by banks I guess as you guys described
and so the process of sort of going
getting access to the tools and the
infrastructure that would enable you to
go and programmatically charge a credit
card basically involve this kind of
mortgage like application process for
you to go to the bank and try to
describe their idea your idea to them
and sort of convince them that they
should support it and then the B kind of
weeks of setup and paperwork and faxes
and probably Latin and so so hey it was
just kind of
hi barrier to entry and overhead and
then when you kind of actually got
access to it I mean you're it's a
fundamental ease of a technology service
right and it was as good as sort of many
of you are the technology services
offered by banks and so we started
working on it I mean literally because
we were frustrated and surprised it
didn't exist and I think something that
may be somewhat important is we actually
didn't think was that big a deal we were
working on some iPhone apps on the side
at the same time and we kind of kept
working on both they're working iPhone
apps I'm working on stripe or as it was
known at the time and slash dead slash
payments we were Great Britain group
excellent the brand angle
I was basically like eight months later
it took kind of majority of a year so
before we realized that there might be
something kind of substantively
interesting there and the CAD the
particular thing that sort of
crystallized was the realization that
means kind of hard to Ballpark into kind
of fermi estimate but in and around to
3% of total consumer spending it takes
place kind of on the internet or through
the internet today and so you know that
is to say 98% 97% does not and then if
you kind of think about what that looks
like in the US what that looks like for
you what it looks like if you're
courting how about the direction of all
that sort of intern appears it seems so
obvious that is kind of far more that's
going to be enabled it's going to be
happening and so forth and so despite
the kind of veneer of maturity to online
commerce kind of the the who knows
twenty eight percent forty eight percent
that will be happening in the future
that that's kind of yet to be enabled
and so kind of eight nine months in we
started to realize that that's when we
decided to take leave from school okay
Troy's probably will see yep
watch it and actually just stepping
through to one other caveat this and
just I guess this has been kind of
framed as the disruptors versus the
disrupted I think it is kind of
important to remember that and I don't
if you guys have heard of Wang or
Osborne or sort of like it Silicon
Valley is well known as being sort of a
cradle of entrepreneurship and new
companies but it is just as successful
in being a grave Lange grew to billions
of dollars in annualized revenue like
Osborne group
ian's of dollars annualized revenue tens
of thousands of employees and not only
do these companies subsequently fail
Hwang had an ignominious bankruptcy in
1992 but like not only did they fail but
you haven't even heard of them right and
so I would just basically take
everything I say with a grain of salt
mm-hmm
that is your like disclaimer of joining
a technology company yes so I can attest
to how hard it was to add billing
software before stripe existed when we
started box.the I'd say about one third
of our entire code base that we had to
initially write had to just deal with
getting payments from our customers so
you can imagine all the wasted time and
innovation there and a lot of Latin and
a lot of faxes so maybe just fast
forward to today just key stats of the
company how big is it how much have you
guys raised how many customers look like
set up said that sort of set us up for
where we are now right so we don't we
circulated last night or the night
before you might have seen what's been
written in the press that it's been
estimated of tens of billions of dollars
being processed by the company that's
the estimate there was in the article
and we're were 350 people ish
I guess our age is publicly observable
that's five years old and oh and we have
a really fun hangout to actually truth
true story but I wanted to kick Aaron
out of my house at 4:00 a.m. pretend to
describe to me how enterprise software
is better than consumer software so I
think equally fun but know one of the
one other one other stat is we did
reveal for that article that 27% of
Americans bought from a stripe user in
the last year oh that's cool which is up
from I think was 3.8 percent in the
convey your preceding two years ago and
so that's what percentage of all those
people know that stripe was behind that
transaction we don't measure that and
it's up to the merchant like what
percentage of websites keep your brand
and you're sort of like and we don't
even okay but like in theory a third to
half of this room as you stripe and I
know from proof for this kind of cord
are you presenting right okay like what
do you power what kind of like on-demand
services department people might
Kickstarter OpenTable lifts okay this
card got home it's a lot of services
cool okay so so I actually on that
though are your customers primarily the
new tech disruptors or are you starting
to sell to some of the big online
retailers that around a while who does
it look like so the vast majority of
stripes customers are relatively new
technology companies so we are you're
like pro startups right yes got it great
and what on so what do you think about
the kind of core competitive advantage
of stripe you mentioned in the founding
story kind of in there I mean the the
answers was in there but just just so we
get to the essence of what is stripe all
about why are you guys so disruptive how
would you how do you think about that
like when you think about product
decisions when you think about why why
developers usually what is like the the
bottom line so I think although the
tendency when stead of describing the
sort of the the product advantages are
the business that I'm sure ever to kind
of over intellectualize it and I
actually I think Clayton Christensen is
kind of a prime example of this we're
sort of you know you're always looking
for kind of the structural reason why
this stuff is kind of necessarily so and
Christians and has sort of struggled so
much to sort of get his head around
Apple where it's kind of not that
complicated it's just these are
systemically better products right and I
think iOS and Android is kind of another
great example of this where I mean
feature for feature they're essentially
at parity or again the difference
between they were kind of
inconsequential but there's no kind of
rigorous structural framework for
describing polish or smooth out
or ambient superiority or sort of
whatever it is that distinguishes them
and yet it really matters I mean I would
wager that in this room Tory ninety
percent of people use iPhones since I
teach the Android case Silicon Valley
reality distortion field how many of you
have iPhones versus Android phones there
you go how much did the profits of
mobile exactly after I go into that iOS
ecosystem yes I think it's a 60 50 60 70
percent that's gotta be a low number
right well I was gonna go I'm going 90
in my head okay you have to look at it
and adjacencies and search and fair
point people make from that yeah and no
I mean I think Android is a great
business move by Google but right it is
but back to string the metal rack okay
so all that to say that I think first
stripe the that this is the primary
thing I the thing is sort of like
enabled certainly all of our initial
traction was that it was just a better
product you could set it up faster it
was easier to understand because it was
kind of easier to both understand and to
set up and people were more likely to do
something with it than doesn't there's a
fallacy instead of assuming that
everyone is going to integrate something
they might just decide to not bother and
so we were able to sort of by lowering
the activation energy more people just
went with that experiment or decided to
pursue that idea or so whatever the case
might be and then kind of once they got
things up and running it was much easier
to operate their business up sort of
ongoing basis with stripe because stripe
sort of sits at this kind of fairly
important Nexus right I mean we're
integrated in the app or in the website
and we kind of were the conduit for the
business's revenue it's where they go to
kind of manage a lot of their customer
data and so forth there were all these
kind of additional areas and I guess
maybe this gets a bit a question to
which we can kind of expand over time
but the initial one was really the the
product quality in the ease of use the
second one is the first generation of
Internet companies sort of existed by
and large on the Internet in the sense
that I mean Yahoo Google Facebook the
sort of I mean you spend a lot of time
on them and they're monetized primarily
through advertising because as you point
out to tech companies are sort of now
tracking their way into the rest of the
economy and the kind of default business
model for I mean most of the economy is
not advertising but I mean just charging
people for things right and so I think
we've also kind of benefited from that
structural shift and then a lot of these
companies actually looking to do things
that aren't just charging a customer but
do something maybe a little bit more
sophisticated and so for example in this
company I mentioned lyft doesn't just
charge their customers in the mobile app
they also store the payment details so
you can be kind of frictionlessly build
they support multiple payment mechanisms
it's kind of Apple pay and credit cards
and you know therefore over time and
then they need to pay out the drivers
and pay out the drivers involved sort of
verifying the identities of the drivers
and actually lifts just launched
something called Express pay were sort
of rather than transferring the money
slowly over ACH the drivers get the
money instantly kind of paid to their
debit card which is I mean a huge deal
if you're sort of living to living
paycheck to paycheck as such a large
fraction of the country is and so
businesses are increasing doing more
sophisticated things with payments or
with money and then sort of stripe is
has been able to kind of expand the
suite of services such that you actually
can't get the same set of things
elsewhere right if you want to do
something like Express pay to instantly
send money to a debit card that's not
something you can get somewhere else and
so one ease of use to increase
functionality know if you is the CEO of
stripe been able to navigate some of the
relationships with the other incumbents
in both the payments and the financial
services space you were invested by both
American Express and Visa and they might
I assume certain parts of people in
those organizations might look at stripe
and be excited by what's possible and
might some people might be a little
concerned about how it might reorient
the landscape how is your company
approach the relationships with larger
companies like that have been around for
many many years well I think there is
first of all again - mistake - its kind
of very easy to look at this stuff as
kind of zero-sum and but like the
economy as a whole is not a zero sum
like we're allocating a much larger set
of dollars today than we were 20 years
ago hundred years ago etc and so kind of
you know this was kind of super
interesting but on the one hand I think
that an important framing aspect to it
is it is possible for it to be positive
some and the the existence of winners
doesn't necessarily mean
that there will be losers there may be
losers but it's not necessarily gonna be
the case and I mean because stripes kind
of thesis is again kind of the idea of
bringing this two percent to 20 percent
or 40 50 percent kind of who knows and
it's a jelly bean expansionary there
aren't a whole lot of companies who are
sort of directly threatened or imperiled
by it right it's not one - it's you guys
have probably shocked to hear that I
think some tech companies are kind of
frequently and to their detriment kind
of mistakenly hubristic and I think this
is sort of especially common for
whatever reason infant a car payments
whatever where people have these kind of
grandiose delusions about how in this
kind of incredibly complicated and sort
of intertwined space they're going to
obviate everyone in one fell swoop with
their sort of phenomenal new thing that
renders everybody must have been boxes
new products right you know honestly we
were pretty careful to sort of try to be
deliberate about where we think we can
do better and where we don't need to try
to write off you know everything's been
built over the last 50 years and so
honestly I think credit cards get kind
of a tough rap these days I think
they've done a pretty impressive job
like blanketing the worlds or a large
fraction of it with sort of a
frictionless kind of credit extending
simple easy to use pan mechanism like
works pretty well you can imagine things
that might work a little bit better but
you know by and large I think it's very
good and so we thought we could sort of
systematic beagle and sort of assemble
this set of capabilities and kind of
existing functions that existed and
expose that you know all of it in a way
more straightforward into the easy to
integrate way but sort of the idea of
again replacing all of it seems like a
land war in Asia and so and so in
general our strategy has been to to not
try to compete with too many of these
folks and I mean I mean there's kind of
some discussion of you know whether
we're competitive
the card networks have this filled us
and so forth I mean we're we're bringing
so much new transaction volume to the
card networks rails what what when you
think about kind of to Rob's question
though a little bit further so in the
supply chain of payments and in commerce
right there are things that are sort of
in front of you and below you like like
you need the credit card you know to use
stripe there are some things that you
you do obviate a bit because you're kind
of compressing the stack to some extent
would you at least agree that it's not
sort of zero-sum in some of the things
that you compress you don't have to get
into like which things those are but
there are things below you that you can
essentially abstract from the developer
that does go away in this world is that
would that be accurate the slipping
requirement video right yeah and nobody
will be dispatched no and you know there
there is a legacy set of businesses the
term was briefly up there somewhere
ISOs that sends for independent sales
organization and there was previously a
sort of well it sort of made sense I
think through the kind of 1970s 1980s
sort of kind of well business lens at
the time we're sort of everything that
wasn't kind of obviously part of your
core competency you wanted to outsource
in some capacity and so the banks and
card network collectively kind of felt
like well this grubby business of
signing up merchants that's kind of
pretty labor-intensive it's not very
efficient we should kind of federated
out to sort of all these independent
entities independent sales organizations
the problem is that kind of once you do
that the heterogeneity kind of entails
all these separate kind of non
cooperating companies means that it's
very difficult to change the shape of
the industry right and so then when the
internet comes along and sort of that
changes the nature of the product you
might want to offer it's extremely
difficult to do so just in the same way
that it's very difficult to sort of
advance things in the windows ecosystem
or in the Android ecosystem as compared
to Apple sort of its record exactly
classic kind of horizontal versus
vertical segmentation or fragmentation
or everyone to slice it and so those
ISOs collectively I mean none of them
are very big but
sort of collectively they are worse off
in a world in which stripe does really
well right and that is that was very
diplomatic no back to you actually I'm
going to change the the the angle of the
conversation for five seconds so instead
of worrying about whether the the peer
financial services and institution
implications of stripe let's actually go
to this idea that you guys power the
digital economy and many of the changes
in that digital world because like let's
assume that if the way we buy cars and
use cars and use insurance and use
services those are companies selling
cars in stripe yes yeah yeah so there
but but as as the industrial world moves
digital yes um it does sound like there
are completely new types of experiences
that relate to payments that you guys
can help an able incumbents and
industrialists to respond with so
totally I think like you know online
media or newspapers and and their use of
payments and how can they build better
relationship for their customers are
though how do you think about that
landscape and sort of digitizing the
offline world yes and so in some ways
stripe is a great bet on sort of human
laziness in the sense that we're a bet
that people will prefer to do things
from their phone then sort of going to
physical places in person yes I mean
that kind of tongue-in-cheek but you
know people sometimes grab the
smartphone as a magic word is just
convenient so well you know this is kind
of that this is the framing the
smartphone as kind of a magic one for
the real world which may be a yet kind
of more virtual more virtuous way to
frame the laziness and the indolence but
I mean for example there's a there's a
company called BP BEP I think was
actually one of the articles and I mean
you can front your phone and you can
literally choose your car and you can
choose the color whatever and like tap
by I guess and literally a trailer comes
with a car and there's a big boat tied
around us and you now have the time
right for cars indeed yes
but I think they're something very
significant here we're like you no
longer need to go to the car dealership
because that's kind of I guess kind of
we don't make $25,000 purchases on your
phone let's go say I mean I think going
to the car dealership is kind of the
Platonic ideal of things we don't want
to do right and so and so there is kind
of this idea of stripe what kind of
powering the well let's call the
digitization because it's better than
the I don't know the laser thing or
something right but there's that and
then secondly that there is something
despite my kind of um kind of erstwhile
pessimism about the US economy or the
dinah isn't there of I mean I do think
that there is some things have
incredibly potent to this kind of
technology powered restructuring yes and
III do broadly think it's true that sort
of as we look at a snapshot of the
economy in 30 or 40 years time a very
large fraction of us will be occupied by
companies that consider to take
advantage of the things you're
describing you guys are a bet on that
correct as you're growing your business
you said 350 people and and you're
continuing to scale as you as you add
more more people and customers that
you're supporting how are you going to
ensure what are you trying to do to
enforce that you stay lean that you stay
quick and all the things that we talked
about it being responsive and agile and
you don't get into the same challenges
right other large organizations be they
companies universities or the way so I'm
not sure that it's entirely possible and
in the sense that and it's just kind of
it's one of the depressing things about
life but I like when you think about the
sort of calculus from well if your goal
is to survive just like to endure as an
entity be it individual or an
organization whatever right kind of you
can't just take that sort of a goodie V
and you have to take bets that have a
very small probability of killing you
right and so I think the kind of
regulatory example is sort of a good one
in that if some large established entity
is presented with a proposition which
could 10x their market cap if it
succeeds and you know destroy them
because they're all in jail or something
if it fails and it's big
50 kind of bad I mean that's tremendous
on an Eevee basis and yet if the
strategy the disposition the business
with regard to risk is to take those
bets then I mean it just doesn't last
very long right and because it of yours
to take kind of 1 minus 0.5 too many
powers before it's kind of the the most
likely thing and so you know the
manifestation think of that for the
large companies is in order to endure
they have to be irrationally risk-averse
and and that goes I mean that's not a
statement about the coordination cost of
larger organizations or anything's bad
that's just a basic statement about a
state or just again endurance says as
anything um after that first often so
certainly now we are less risky than we
were on on day one and I think but
that's kind of the extreme pessimistic
view I think obviously you can hope to
do a little bit better than than many
other organizations again sort of well
but by virtue of getting to sort of
observe everything that they did and
sort of simply getting to kind of
springboard off that and getting to sort
of start things from scratch you you've
a much better chance and then pretty
substantially I mean in particular
instead of stripes case doesn't doesn't
go in every case when stripes case
what's kind of going on is like a shift
in industry in that we're supplanting
banks who certainly were not about
software or technology or these ISOs who
are literally kind of going door-to-door
selling people and we're sort of
shifting industry to actually playing on
this kind of technology software
programming design whatever playing
field and so kind of in that sense we're
you know as an organization level far
better equipped and then I guess the the
question of how do you just run an
effective human organization and not
sort of descend into salsify
calcification and part to go on too long
okay but you will attempt to not do that
using real-time strategy when you think
about your I guess disruptive potential
whether it's in financial services or
just as you touch other parts of the
economy do you think that because
because a big part of this is thinking
about what are the what are the
strengths of a digital
company in the mindset and in the
approach do you think about either data
in terms of how much data that you learn
from and can improve the product on do
you think of network effects so keeping
a people within the payment ecosystem
what are the modern ways of competitive
kind of advantage you think about
developing within stripe right um that's
a good question and honestly I go back
and forth on the importance of data like
not with regard to start in particular
but it's like in general in the industry
and that sort of it's always in every
incumbents interests to kind of to
broadcast its importance right and
because it sort of makes their position
appear more secure and so I think you
kind of have to discount every time
someone could have trusted the
importance of the data I think you
should just be slightly skeptical do a
montage video of incumbents talk about
data so and you know it well it it's not
clear to me in most case instead of
whether kind of a company's value is
kind of primarily based on some kind of
flow or some kind of stock and to what
extent the stock of data kind of in fact
enables the flow and I think you know
one way and this kind of pertains the
network effect is I think the sort of in
general the term network effects should
be banned and or more simply it's an it
needs kind of more specificity in the
sense that there are Network effects for
the value of a node is kind of not
proportional to the distance between two
nodes and so for example when you're on
eBay or Airbnb actually kind of a
marginal additional thing being sold or
or a place to stay is kind of how
valuable that is is kind of independent
of me because I might want to go
anywhere right and or or I might want to
buy anything whereas when you think
about for example of social networks
it's obviously kind of very much a
function of the distance from me if some
person in some distant country joins a
social network you know in general I
don't care whereas you know I very much
care whether my friends are on it or not
and and I think that so when you kind of
talk about the data sort of in each case
or the kind of accumulated stock and
asset I think it's a really depends
which when you're talking about and sure
enough you observe that in the social
networks there's actually this kind of
pretty rapid turnover be it sort of
snapchat whatsapp Facebook Twitter
Instagram Yik yak and know what kids use
these days but definitely yeah okay yep
and whereas eBay LinkedIn and kind of so
many these are original kind of web
Giants I mean they they don't have the
best web design and and I think that's
I'm not accidental that they don't have
to wear do this like ferociously
competitive social network attack with
regard to stripe oh it's active what
last thing on that point and many of you
probably read zero to one and by Pierre
teal and he kind of lays out I think for
sources of monopoly or whatever that
tech companies can have I think it's
sort of economies of scale network
effects consumer brand and and just kind
of core technology that sort of others
don't have there's a professor here at
Stanford Hamilton Helmer true you guys
are friends and he has a slightly more
elaborate version of this I think his
version actually really good I think he
has seven powers he calls him and so
just consider a plug for Hamilton
Helberg and don't name them all do you
like it do you think it matters can't
talk about our strategy on video no and
okay one important Network effect yes
stripe is the network effect of the mind
chair and all the developers and they
and I think this is kind of now people
talk about sort of the power of
developers and the rise of developers
ever I think there's actually a lot of
other getting out there just like so
many new runs and deal cells in their
heads they were sort of wired for stripe
and not something else and that makes it
much easier for each business to go in
it's literally cheaper it integrates
right because easier to find people who
know it and yes so you bring down the
friction of using stripe because of the
broader community that uses it and so a
little bit of a network effect
yeah and then yeah great okay so that
was uh that was a good overview of your
relationship to the industrialist
dilemma and how you guys are approaching
the digital side of that so with that I
think we'll don't want papers and
thanking Patrick